ja um punkt vier uhr sind die
spezialkräfte hier vor gefahren haben
sich herangeschlichen an die tür und
haben eine explosion verursacht an der
tür und die tür dann aufgesprengt ein
zweites mal an der wohnungstür gab es
auch eine explosion
auch dort wurde die wohnungstür
aufgesprengt und anschließend wurde eine
blendgranate in die wohnung geworfen und
dort wurde der beschuldigte dann
festgenommen
anschließend sind ermittler in die
wohnung gekommen haben umfangreiche
beweise gesichert und spürhunde haben
das ganze noch einmal akribisch
untersucht und dann wurden die sachen
aus der wohnung heraus getragen
vor wenigen stunden wurden diese
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen abgeschlossen
jetzt werden die sichergestellten sachen
ausgewertet und wir schauen jetzt mal
auf die wohnungstür wo diese explosion
von der wohnungstür stattgefunden hat
viel ist von dieser tür jetzt nicht mehr
zu sehen nur noch der türrahmen und die
tür steht jetzt offen ja das ganze hat
auch ordentlich gespielt hat anwohner
berichteten uns dass sie alle aus dem
schlaf geweckt wurden durch diesen
lauten knall durch diese lauten knall
und ja das zu der durchführung du stehst
jetzt in wuppertal es wurde an mehreren
städten wohnungen und firmen durchsucht
wer genau wurde also bei dir
festgenommen ja hier an dieser stelle
wohnt der hauptbeschuldigte es handelt
sich um samir al seien bekannt durch
diese großfamilie als sein und in
anderen städten wurden weitere
familienmitglieder festgenommen
wie genau sind die polizisten jetzt
diesen klaren dieser großfamilie auf die
spur gekommen
entscheidend war ja die anzeige von dem
autohändler aus venlo
der hat das ganze ins rollen gebracht
als auf eine anzeige von dieser familie
gestoßen im netz die familienmitglieder
haben einen rolls royce online gestellt
und wollten diesen verkaufen den wert
von einer sechsstelligen summe und der
autohändler aus venlo ist dann auch wie
auf die familie reingefallen